عاده ما تكون البدايه من الارياف والبلدات
النائيه وحيث يتنقل موظفوا هيئه الاحصاء
برفقه رجال الامن المسلحين لعد السكان
تفاصيل دقيقه وشامله يتضمنها التعداد
السكاني في باكستان بهدف توزيع الموارد
وبشكل عابر بين افراد الشعب
الى المدن حيث تتقاطع المسارات السياسيه
تحديدا
يصل موظفوا هيئه الاحصاء وهنا يبدا الجدل
نعتقد انه يجب ان تنظم انتخابات اولا
وتتشكل حكومه لديها تفويض شعبي تنظم هذا
التعداد السكاني والا قبل الانتخابات يعني
انه موجه
الاحصاء السكاني السابع في تاريخ باكستان
يتم تنظيمه ايضا رقميا وحيث يمكن لاي
مواطن رفع بياناته تلقائيا ما اثار جدلا
حتى بين اركان السلطه لاسيما وان نتائج
اخر تعداد سكاني تسببت في خلاف واسع عندما
اظهرت ان عدد السكان ارتفع باكثر من خمسين
بالمئه وكان يفترض بناء على ذلك ان يزداد
عدد ممثلي المقاطعات الاعلى سكانا في
البرلمان
ان تمسك لجنه الانتخابات بمحدوديه الدوائر
الانتخابيه اجد الخلافه الذي ما يزال
مستمرا حتى الان
انا وزير ولم اكن اعرف بنيه الحكومه
القيام بتنفيذ هذا التعداد رقميا والسماحي
بناء على ذلك لكل من اراد بالدخول الى
صفحه على الانترنت لكتابه ما شاء فيها هذا
يعني ان التعداد لن يعكس ابدا حقيقه وضع
السكان وهو مرفوض بالكامل
نقول لكل جهه تعترض على عملنا ان ناس
سنوفر متابعه دقيقه ورقميه لكل التفاصيل
فالهدف هو ان تكون لدى واضع السياسه صوره
واضحه وشامله عن كل تفاصيل البلاد
ان اتفقت الاطراف السياسيه المعنيه
بالتعداد السكاني على نتائجه وهو امر
مستبعد فانه سيتعين على الحكومه واستنادا
لنتائج الاحصاء ان توصي لجنه الانتخابات
بتعديل عدد وحدود الدوائر الانتخابيه
المعتمده حاليا وهو ما سيحتاج ربما في
مرحله لاحقه لتعديل دستوري او مرسوم رئاسي
عاده ما تتسبب
هذه المره الخلافات بدات مع بدايه التعداد
وحتى بين اطراف الحكومه الائتلافيه ما
يدفع للاعتقاد بان الخلافه سيمتد الى
مرحله اعلان النتائج وربما الى ما بعد ذلك
عبد الرحمن مطر الجزيره روى البنتى